vous aviez notre civilisation est en
train de s'effondrer
qu'est ce que vous ferez est-ce que vous
continueriez votre lit comme avant il ya
d'abord eu la chance de perdre pour
dépression en école de commerce vous
venez vite compris que je serai pas
heureux dans une carrière à classique
j'étais en quête de sens j'avais envie
d'avoir un métier qui est du sort pour
moi et ça m'a rien à créer mon travail
qui m'anime c'est d'aider les leurs a
incarné avec multiples années de séance
et à rayonner encore ça nous pousse
encore par la nuit les façons de changer
le monde
à son échelle comme dans les histoires
notamment de 7 ce qui bouge qui
construisent demain et qui rayonne par
la langue allemand prend la forme de
conférences de livres et surtout d'une
chaîne youtube vous savez les
changements notre stand deux heures
jusqu'à il ya un an j'ai pris une claque
la claque de l'effondrement de la
civilisation basée sur les énergies
fossiles
ça a commencé vers 2018 n'était alors
famille à noël et mon frère à votre avis
d'apparence anodine manuel du
transitions de rentrer chez moi
et le jour où au début c'est vrai j'ai
compris à quel point notre société est
assis sur une bombe à retardement
la fin du pétrole abondant et bon marché
ce qui si pour moi c'était un sujet que
vous connaissez mais de manière plutôt
abstraite et mentale la 7e nul très
concret concrètement quasiment tous les
objets autour de nous ont nécessité du
pétrole
ce soit pour leur fabrication ou la leur
transport téléphone ou vêtements ou
notre alimentation
la question c'est de se dire et si le
coût du pétrole explose et donc le fou
du transport aux tic
principalement ce pétrole on va faire de
notre société à volos dessus on pourra
plus à apporter autant de produits par
exemple pour l'alimentation comment est
ce qu'on va faire pour trouver la
nourriture localement alors que la
plupart de l'île sont pas du tout
autonome en la matière une ville comme
rennes par exemple
à quatre jours de stocks alimentaires
cas de ruptures d'approvionnements ya
toujours eu largement j'ai compris à
quel point la fin du pétrole abondant et
pour marcher ça pouvait expliquer des
choses beaucoup plus gras et des longues
coupures de courant peut aussi amener à
des pénuries
une famine donc aussi des conflits les
épidémies et l'atelier mer mais on a
laissé dire ça on est en plein suicide
collectif
oui il est sympa c'est tout cas je sais
je comprends très bien
tout le monde peut faire un tête x
positif et plein d'espoir pour ce que
vous avez regardé mon comité dit sauf
que si vous aviez un français est ce que
vous voudrez de sap à nantes après mais
en sachant pas pour une patte contre
pour y soigner
apprendre à dire à mr bah c'est la même
chose pour cette question du pétrole et
plus largement pour l'effondrement de la
civilisation
je le prends cette pac sur pétrole mal
là et dans la foulée jeudi les livres de
pages le service sur l'effondrement
d'ailleurs pris les aventures je suis
pas vous servir avait lu le livre mais
mon père en faire que ça va payer
aujourd'hui je regarde aussi les vidéos
très bien réalisé de partager sympa de
rigueur dieu et enfin beaucoup plus
récemment la série l'effondrement des
partis promettent à quoi pourrait
ressembler un scénario
en france le fond c'est quoi pour
simplifier puisque c'est un sujet assez
dax est systémique
c'est le processus selon lequel notre
civilisation basée sur les énergies
fossiles industrielle est en train de
s'effondrer se déliter c'est ce qu'il
est et si demain la majorité des gens
n'avaient plus accès à des ressources de
base l'eau l'alimentation en électricité
tous les sens et si ces ressources
devenues rares beaucoup vite que prévu
la qui prend que le sait plus du tout
une question de crise pétrole
l'expriment hâtive d'un côté ou de
l'autre
non c'est toute la société qui est en
train de s'effondrer
toute la civilisation et tous les
piliers des activités à sion sont plus
en plus fragile
ce soit les énergies fossiles non par
exemple avec le pétrole l'agriculture en
finance la justice sociale c est que
tous ses piliers
ils sont liées entre elles sont plus des
mois inter défend là et puis donc s'il y
en a quelques-uns qui s'effondre pas au
mieux il sera vite
seulement les autres au pire il les
entraîne dans leur chute
même des dominos prenons l'exemple kling
l'axé ce qui met aujourd'hui d'après les
scientifiques sont continues comme ça tu
es sur une série thouars de +3 à plus
sales degrés d'ici la fin du siècle
ça veut dire que si ça + 10 2 grec sur
les continents parce que l'air au dessus
des continents réchauffantes environ
deux fois plus que le lait rang suivi
des dossiers
je sais ça fuse 10 degrés ça fait
beaucoup
c'est pas arrivé depuis trois millions
d'années
il ya plein de zones du globe qui se
complaît les cultivables pour
l'agriculture même attaque pour l'homme
on en est là un autre exemple sur la
biodiversité
notre papa s'est conduit la vitesse
d'extinction des espèces est 1000 fois
supérieur à la normale il faut
on estime que 30 ans la moitié du vivant
est disparue ont synthétisé on est en
train de détruire la vie sur terre est
la priorité numéro une de nos exigences
et la fera sens hélas comprend que que
j'avais répondu je crois que je savais
je croyais que mesurer l'ampleur de la
catastrophe
j'avais plusieurs déclic écolo je suis
militant humaniste n'a rien gagné et
c'est en fait à l'image de notre société
j'ai longtemps cru que la crise
climatique notamment
c'était un truc un peu lointain abstrait
et deux pour les générations futures
c'est pas pour tout de suite tout de
suite et la comprends que ça va bouger
tout le monde partout même en france et
qu'on parle de choses graves
on parle de guerre on parle d'épidémie
venus par le 200 millions à un milliard
de livres en thématiques de 25 minutes
dans les pays acp vote tenu de la crise
climatique et que je verrai ça d'une
ville en parle de génération actuelle et
non seulement des relations futures en
bas revenus ouais c'est pire que ce que
je croyais enfants que des milliards de
personnes qui risquent le monde comprend
que tôt ou tard ça va a dit calment
changé ma vie et celle de janvier m
et j'ai l'impression que ces cinq ans
notre société est en train de prendre
conscience collectivement lentement
alors devant mais de plus en plus vite
heureusement que peut-être que dans
quelques années ce sera à qui pour la
majorité des gens qui espèrent l'urgence
de la situation
mais pour l'instant c'est pas car elle
c'est pour ça que ça me tient à coeur de
vous en parler parce que plus la
majorité des citoyens pour a conscience
de l'urgence d'agir plus ce sera facile
de changer la société et des mouvements
citoyens de masse qui obtiennent des
changements rapidement parce que pour
l'instant non seulement il n'y a pas
grand chose qui change mais surtout on
se comporte peu de tout petit on était
en cas de crise majeure
alors c'est cap may pour faire simple
c'est pas possible d'avoir une
croissance infinie dans un monde de
ressources finies comme le dit jean paul
ici bas co2 ou pib va falloir choisir
donc depuis un an on pense tous les
jours
à cette question d'effondrement des
effondrements regarde tout autour de moi
et je vois toutes ces choses qui
appartiendront probablement avec bientôt
au passé
soit nous avions de l'eau plust nos
supermarchés de produits importés ou
l'électricité courante l'angop dans la
rue regarde les gens et je veux encore
ils vont se prendre cette claque de
l'effondrement
s'ils ont déjà reçu comment ils vivent
avec quelques changements et du mis en
place dans leur vie depuis
est-ce qu'ils ont conscience de ce qu'il
vient de se passer et moi même ça a
complètement changé mon rapport au futur
maintenant 2 est ce que je veux quand
même des enfants dans une planète
l'habitacle est ce que le devoir changer
de métier plus exactement encore quelles
compétences j'ai moi pour me nourrir se
loger se chauffer et sachant que la
plupart des billets ne sont pas
autonomes
en alimentation en énergie et serra ou
et où être honnête ça a été une année
personnellement son et juments d'être le
seul
il ya plus en plus de gens qui font ce
qu'on appelle de l'éco anxiété voire de
décoder pression face à la situation
actuelle et à toutes ces personnes
j'ai envie de vous dire que vous n'êtes
pas seuls que la situation mondiale et
ce cas les parents c'est comment on
passe à l'action
il ya toute une société à réinventer la
société d'aujourd'hui
elle est malade clairement et qu'on a
l'opportunité d'en créer une c'est
beaucoup plus humaine éclater un peu de
bien repérer ces d'envoi ce qui se passe
des choses là normalement c'est la
partie où vous en faites sur les sushis
sauf que j'aime par son geste
parce que parler de solution ça
sous-entend que le problème était sain
pour le maîtriser mais une solution à un
problème le problème disparaît cela
sous-entend que on peut avoir la
solution simple à quelque chose d'aussi
ces panneaux on a besoin de changer
notre système et ça sous-entend aussi
que les choses pourront rester tel quel
aujourd'hui la question sait plus
comment éviter l'effondrement des
civilisations ça c'est du boulot il ya
soixante dix ans avec le rappeur vidéo
sauf qu'on n'a pas dévié de notre
victoire en matière de l'émission de gaz
à effet de serre n'ont entendu la
question c'est moins limiter cet
effondrement
et comment protéger la vie sur terre
comment construire une autre société de
nardi dès demain il a très bien la rampe
la ville et là il ya plein de choses
incroyables se passe parce que tu
n'arrives à éviter l'augmentation de la
température de jeu parce que d'un
dixième de degré bah ça revient à sauver
des centaines de millions de vies plus
on s'organise tôt et mieux on encaissera
allés chacun vient donc à premier levier
d'action c'est tout simplement de
réduire les émissions de gaz
collectivement produits en moins et
consommer moins c'était collective
minimaliste et low tech qui consomme
moins d'énergie
bref vive dans les limites des
ressources de notre planète ce qui amène
le pied qui s'est beaucoup développé
cette année c'est de se rebeller contre
le système en place qui détruit le divin
ça il ya plein de mouvements citoyens
qui est maire d'hyper aspirants
justement essayer de protéger le vivant
et mettre nos responsables face à la
responsabilité justement pour qu'ils se
bougent ce soit extraction rapidement
par exemple super locales et enfin si
les fondements de notre civilisation ça
signifie la fin d'un monde
ceci le début d'un autre monde et lance
mon post pétrole notamment va il ya
beaucoup de chance qu'il y ait beaucoup
moins de transport du coup du coup la
fille soit la popul au calme donc un
troisième le glaive pour agir c'est
comment est-ce que localement crié des
territoires ou pur plaisir ou plus
autonomes en matière d'alimentation
d'énergie et c est pour ça justement
travaux pis celui de livres du début de
le monde a lancé le mouvement des villes
en transition
libération et individuellement
développer les compétences liées à ces
besoins autonomie par exemple des
compétences en agriculture en
construction ça peut s'avérer être super
j bien sûr il ya beaucoup plus que trois
moyens d'agir et la maison brûle et a
besoin on a besoin de ça on a besoin de
pompiers de soignants en amande a besoin
de lanceurs dalet de fabricants de
lancer un cendrier de formateurs en
premiers secours et en aval on a besoin
de gens qui l'ont construite sur
l'écosystème et ces deux soirs plus
humain et plus ils en ont mais ça lui
laisse un le monde change radicalement
et nous si vous savez que notre
civilisation elle pas en train de
s'effondrer
est ce que vous feriez jusqu'où vous
continueriez catholique alors qu'un
drôle vous voulez jouer dans ce monde
qui s'effondre
au moins vous avez envie de défendre le
vivant parce qu'il m'a dit c'est d'aider
les gens à trouver leur place parce
qu'on dit s'effondre en partagent
l'envié d'une façon de s'engager sur
tout en montrant ce qu'il ya de plus
humain chez l'être humain en partageant
les histoires un peu ce qui est d'autres
lendemains plus souhaitable et l'inspira
secondes
il ya besoin d'amour il ya besoin de
courage alors terminait sur cette
question le monde change radicalement et
plus en plus de citoyens
et vous
[Applaudissements]